I got dozens of emails from people over
the weekend
um uh not over the weekend since last
night saying David you've got to talk
about what happened at the Oscars Will
Smith open hand slapping uh Chris Rock
and it was crazy and you've got to talk
about what happened so we are going to
talk about this on the bonus show today
I wanted to say just a couple of things
about it I am not let me first explain
what happened as I understand it and I
haven't watched the Oscars in more than
10 years but I watched some clips and
read some articles this morning uh Chris
Rock joked about
Will Smith's wife's short haircut Jada
Pinkett Smith which is apparently short
at least in part because of the medical
condition alopecia baldness and Will
Smith apparently didn't like it and when
he walked up to the stage he slapped
Chris Rock and then when he sat back
down he was screaming at him about keep
my wife's name out of your mouth the
reactions exploded some people reacting
along racial lines saying that if this
was rather than two black men a white
man and a black man it would have been
seen completely different
uh one of them would have been arrested
or the other would have been arrested
okay that was one line of analysis
another was this was obviously staged
because in no sane world would this
happen
and then the Oscars just continue I
don't know that that's necessarily the
case the people organizing the Oscars
might have been as shocked by what
happened as anybody else and they didn't
know what the hell to do and they're
like I guess we just continue the show
um I I really don't know at this early
uh point in time what the truth is about
this but uh it is one of the strangest
things I've ever even heard of happening
during the Oscars and we are going to
talk about it in more detail on the
bonus show so I just wanted to say a
little something I want to hear from you
if you're watching on YouTube leave a
comment about what you think happened
was this genuine was this a setup as
summer claiming uh let us know let me
know on Twitter at dpacman and then
we'll talk about it on the bonus show
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
I've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when I use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say I'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up I can delete that virtual
card so I know I'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say I'm
ordering food over the phone but I left
my wallet somewhere I don't have my real
credit card on me I can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not as susceptible to data
breaches and identity theft privacy C is
a totally free service and you'll get
five bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video